I encourage people,
that person that they always wanted, it's still there.
It didn't go anywhere.
That amazing person that you know you are,
it is there, it is there.
If you struggle with weight all your life,
if you struggled with how you respond
in the heat of the moment,
if you found yourself being short-tempered,
if you find yourself always lethargic,
constipated, tired, angry,
you can actually have a complete reversal,
from your diet, to learn in breathing.
We've never been taught how to breathe.
It's unbelievable.
The most important thing you can do for yourself,
we've never been taught.
We never sat down and taught children,
this is how you're suppose to breathe.
How do you deal with stress?
How do you deal with anxiety?
And so go on this amazing journey
of watching how you really start taking care
this most important person in your life,
and that's yourself, and you will never believe
the human being you knew you could always become
it's going to like materialize out of nowhere.
And I just encourage people just to take the leap of faith,
and then start,
let me just try one day a week not having meat,
and you're gonna find out the sun comes out.
(laughs)
And then start,
let me just learn about these different breathing exercises
that have been around for thousands of years,
and what meditation actually is,
and people are going to slowly start adding things
to their repertoire, more and more things,
and they're going to find themselves
becoming this totally different human being,
but the human being that they always were,
and then they're going to really start not just existing
they're gonna start living life every day.
That's Eric Adams,
and this is "The Rich Roll Podcast."
(upbeat music)
"The Rich Roll Podcast," what's happening, people?
Good to be here, good to have you.
As many of you guys know,
I was in New York City recently, a couple weeks ago,
and one of the many occasions for that trip
was the opportunity to sit down
with today's remarkable guest, Brooklyn Borough President
and soon-to-be New York City's next mayor Eric Adams,
and it was an experience that did not disappoint.
You might've heard Eric's name
because as the current democratic nominee
for the mayorship of New York City,
in recent months, this has put him on the map
as a sort of national media figure.
By way of background,
Eric is a former police officer with NYPD.
It's a 22-year career wherein Eric made great progress
reforming that institution from within,
well in advance of it being vogue,
before retiring from the force as a captain
and entering the of politics,
serving four terms as a New York State Senator
before becoming the first African-American
Borough President of Brooklyn.
Those who have followed this mayoral race more closely
likely already know that it's essentially
been focused on one issue, law and order,
and lost in this media cycle about today's guest
is this incredible commitment that he has
to revolutionizing health policy,
which is a direct result of his very personal experience
with Chronic Lifestyle Disease.
Five years ago, at the age of 54,
Eric woke up unable to read his alarm clock
and concerned as you might imagine about his vision,
as well as numbness in his extremities,
he reluctantly goes to the doctor who in turn delivers
this very grim diagnosis of advanced Type 2 diabetes.
Progressive eyesight loss was inevitable,
his nerve damage was leading him
on a path towards amputation,
and going on a battery of medications
for the rest of his life was just an absolute given.
But Eric, refusing to believe his fate was sealed,
decides instead to take matters into his own hands.
Rather than googling living with diabetes,
instead he googles reversing diabetes, and what he finds
is a plethora of supports, science, experts,
many of which have appeared on this show,
that inspired him to ditch his lifelong allegiance
to the standard American diet,
in favor of a whole food plant-based diet.
Within weeks of this nutritional shift
and without any medication whatsoever,
Eric's symptoms subside,
his diabetes indeed reverses over time,
his vision returns, his nerves repair themselves,
and in the months that followed,
he lowers his cholesterol by 30 points, he drops 35 pounds,
and essentially, a new lease on life was born.
Now, five years hence, Eric is the fittest he's ever been.
His remarkable transformation instigated him
to share what he learned and inspired him to create impact
through some pretty radical initiatives
as Brooklyn Borough President to improve the nutrition,
the health, and the lives of New Yorkers and beyond,
and it's a commitment he's adamant about expanding
as New York's next mayor.
It's an incredible story,
well told by an incredible storyteller,
and it's coming right up, but first.
If you're struggling with your diet,
just can't sustain those healthy eating habits,
you're not alone.
Might I suggest The Plantpower Meal Planner.
Our digital toolbox of unlimited access
to thousands of customizable plant-based recipes,
integrated with grocery delivery,
expert support seven days a week,
and so much more, all for just $1.90 a week.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
Okay, back to the show.
(suspensive music)
Okay, Eric Adams, New York City's next mayor.
Here's the thing though.
This isn't really a conversation about politics,
it's a conversation about plants.
The power of plants to heal, told through the lens
of Eric's remarkable journey from ill to well,
and the purpose-driven mission it is birth within him
to revolutionize health across America.
I appreciate Eric for taking time
out of his busy schedule to talk with me.
We only had a tight hour,
but I think we really made the most of it.
I suspect you will find this conversation inspiring,
wanting to know more about Eric,
in which case you should certainly check out his book,
"Healthy at Last: A Plant-Based Approach to Preventing
and Reversing Diabetes and Other Chronic Illnesses."
And with that, I give you Eric Adams.
(upbeat music)
Thank you so much for doing this.
No, you're welcome, you're welcome.
Rachel sings your praises, she's like my veteran.
Yeah , we've been going back and forth
actually I think for years trying to make this happen,
but the timing, I always trust the timing,
and this is a very, very special moment for you right now,
so I feel privileged to grab an hour out of your busy day.
Yes.
Because we only have an hour,
I mean there's so many things
that I would love to explore with you,
the current problems New York City faces,
gun control, police reform and the like,
but because we only have an hour, to make the most of that,
I think that we would be best served by focusing
the conversation on health and your personal health journey,
your commitment to sharing what you've learned,
and leveraging that experience really
to create policy change and programs,
systems to address everything from food insecurity
to improving personal health
in the lives of your constituents.
So your aim for that?
First of all, the earring looks good though.
(laughs)
Can you tell that story really quick?
On, I wanna go to that,
but I wanna go to something else that you touched on,
which is so important.
We don't connect the dots.
What we are facing, is all the same thing.
And we sometimes believe of that is separate, but it's not,
the universe we live in is an ecosystem.
And so everything's part of that ecosystem
and we live on this unbalanced, it throws off everything.
And so you use the term system, which is important,
and you also use the term of, we wanna talk about my health,
but we are unhealthy society.
And everything we do is unhealthy.
We have a junk food mindset,
both for our nutritional standards,
as well as our emotional standards, our spiritual,
we are really in a bad place and it's being expedited
through this our addiction to social media,
that's the McDonald's of our mind.
Sure, and you can't solve the big problems,
you can't solve or address the macro problems
without addressing the micro problems,
the problems within ourselves.
We have to carry a certain vibration
of truth and integrity and authenticity.
There has to be an integration, right?
You have to be in balance with yourself and your environment
before you can step up to the podium and talk about changing
the problems that affect all of us collectively.
Well said and so if,
and the first step towards correction
is with a AA talks about, you have to acknowledge.
I mean--
Yeah, you have to, I mean I've been in AA forever.
So you're gonna speak my own language.
One of the things I always say, podcast is,
one of the tropes of AA is
"You cannot transmit something you haven't got."
Like you have to be living it, exuding it.
You have to be an exemplar of the values and the ideas
that you're espousing, otherwise it rings hollow.
And I think in this junk food,
social media culture that we find ourselves in
and there's a lot of people
proselytizing about this and that,
but a lot of that is nonsense because talk is cheap.
And if you're not actually,
living your life in accordance with what you're preaching,
I think people's intent is one of the things
about social media is that we're all very attuned
to what's real and what's fake, especially young people
they can see it a mile away.
And that's why I think there's so much strength and gravitas
in your message oriented around health
because of your own personal experience.
Well say, well say and you know,
and that connects to the whole earring piece
on the campaign trail and--
Bring it back to the story.
You're gonna answer this question.
(chuckles)
On the campaign trail
and I was with my son the first time it happened
that a group of young people that was just disenchanted.
And he said, "We hear you politicians always come,
you say everything we don't believe."
And young man stood up and say, "Well, you know what?
If you get elected to mayor."
and I said, "Well, first this is the primary."
He says, "Well but if you win the primary,
Would you pitch your is?"
(laughs)
And I said, "Yes, I would."
He said, "Yeah."
And everybody, the whole crowd was like, yeah,
BSBS and so they, after the primary, my son said,
promise, made promise, kept debt.
And so went to the store,
sat in the chair and got to his peers.
And it was really sending the message,
that this is a new day, this is a new day.
You're going to see an elected official,
that's going to push the boundaries
and that's willing to say, I'm going to keep my promise.
Number one,
I'm not going to be on the campaign trail saying one thing
and then, getting in governance and do another
and that's what is about.
Yeah, did the kid who originally challenged you?
Do you know who that, do you have his name
and stuff like that?
We put it on social media.
I saw that.
The team is probably
looking for him, that he is going to--
I know, I feel like
you need to have a Tet attack with that kid.
(laughs)
And it is really,
this moment is exciting for so many reasons.
And my team watched me evolve, just as a human being,
this evolution that I'm going through,
I'm nowhere near where I'm going to end,
but I'm evolving in so much.
And it was never about the destiny.
My team heard me say this over and over again.
It was never about do I become mayor?
It's the journey.
All I know is this journey is preparing me
for what my real purpose is
and the hurdles I had to go through.
And this was a tough, tough, tough journey.
We had incoming coming from all over the place,
but we remained, we had a motto,
stay focused, no distractions and grind, that was it.
(chuckles)
Yeah, I asked you right
before we started recording, like how you feeling,
and you're like, you gotta stay grounded.
I can't fly too high.
But you got a lot coming at you right now
and I can't imagine what that's gonna look like.
I mean, at this point, New York City is 70% Democrat,
it's not a foregone conclusion,
but in all likelihood you'll be the mayor.
And in that situation,
there's gonna be all kinds of insanity swirling around you.
Like how do you stay grounded with that job?
By being true to yourself.
I know there are things I'm able to do
and things I am not able to do.
And just remain committed,
wake up every day with the same focus that I've have had.
You can't invent yourself a day one as being mayor
if you didn't have those same practices
while you were going through life.
And so, growing up in South Jamaica Queens,
mom moving us there from Brownsville,
going through my entire educational experience,
cry myself to sleep I mean, literally,
of why can't learn, why I'm in the classroom
and I'm being bullied as the dumb kid and getting Ds,
no matter how hard I tried
and being told by my teachers I was lazy.
I know for getting third grade
one teacher smacking me so hard,
that it left a hand print on my face
because they thought that
I just didn't put in enough effort,
but I was trying every night I was grinding.
And it wasn't until I got into college,
overheard a documentary, a learning disabilities.
And I said, wow, do I have a learning disability?
You got took out the documentary and realized that I did.
And I was able to overcome that learning disability.
Dyslexia or what was it?
It was a combination of ADD and dyslexia.
It was a combination of the two.
So, I was in pretty bad shape.
And I went from a D student to on the Dean's list.
And it was amazing that I was undiagnosed
and my mother not understanding that.
And I still think today that my brother
is dealing with bipolar that was never diagnosed.
And because he never had was lucky
like I was lucky to hear it,
his pathway went totally different from my pathway.
But imagine how many children never had that luck
and they still are suffering from the outcomes.
Yeah, just one of the many epidemics
that we're dealing with right now, mental health.
Especially in the wake of COVID with depression, anxiety,
stress, all the pressures
that everyday people are shouldering,
just trying to pay the bills, make through the day.
That's right and we no longer believe,
that's why this race was important on so many levels.
And that's why the campaign was not only built on a strategy
of how to win, but a strategy of how to tell a story
of the perfectly imperfect human being.
I am so flawed, man.
(laughs)
It's refreshing if we say that.
My campaign guru, Nathan.
He said, "Man, we supposed to be in last place."
(laughs)
Because I am so flawed as a person.
And I wanted to put my flawed persona on Broadway.
I'm wondering everyone who had a learning disability,
everyone who's dealing with diabetes,
everyone who was ever bullied,
everyone who was arrested and beat by police.
I want everyone to see like, listen man,
this guy is able to become the mayor.
(laughs)
Well, I think it's a breath of fresh air
because we've developed this expectation,
of how a politician speaks
and the way they deliver their message.
And these carefully crafted stories
that are meant to check certain boxes
and we've become, inoculated against that.
And there is this thirst, this hunger
for something real and something true.
It goes back to what I was saying earlier,
this idea of people know when something is real
and when it's crafted, when it's manufactured.
Right and that's the greatest gift
I can give New Yorkers,
which I'm hoping cascade throughout the entire country.
Our NOAA knows a lie in what's real.
And we have stopped listening to ourselves.
We know, your spirit won't allow you to accept a lie.
My message resonated with people
because they felt the authentic approach of it.
We carried them, we carried every New York is five Boroughs,
we carry four Boroughs in the city of all ethnicities.
(laughs)
And that was a joy of this race,
because I started to see--
And you know an under dog candidate
kind of creeping your way up or like sneaking past
some bigger names along the way.
And all the shenanigans with the,
all the stuff that got baked into the account
and all of that--
Yes, yes.
There you are man, swinging.
Yes, and it feels good.
And we never, there was never a time
that the team felt as though we couldn't do it.
Never, all we knew we had to do.
Rachel you agree with that?
What you saying right here.
We said to put one foot in front of the other,
that's all we did every day.
We had to raise $11 million.
Think about our astronomical is, $11 million.
Where does a kid from Besta I get $11 million from,
but we just did one fundraiser at a time,
could have been five people, they're writing checks for $10.
We took it and said, thank you.
And then they will call 10 more friends.
(chuckles)
So what do you make of that,
as somebody of this humble upbringing,
who's come so far in your life and achieve so much?
When you reflect on that, what are the lessons?
What are the principles that you've organized
your life around that have allowed you to excel?
We had a rock that we use to hold
that said believe.
And after every event, we will have everyone touch the rock,
because I believe that you just,
as your fingerprints leave your DNA,
your fingerprint of belief.
I believe it leaves a DNA on everything.
The people we come in contact with,
if they believe their DNA of belief
is going to impact you as well.
And we wanted people to start believing in themselves.
And we really believe that we created this,
just this energy of people, of all ethnic groups,
different languages and different cultures.
They just believed.
(chuckles)
That's cool man.
I got to tell you, like looking at you,
you don't look a day over 40.
(laughs)
You really don't, I mean you 61.
Yes.
61, I mean, like just the model of vitality.
So I do wanna get back to the health thing.
Like, let's talk about that.
'Cause that's a crazy story.
And I feel like you mentioned earlier,
the importance of telling a story, how you tell a story,
the story that you are telling.
There's so many issues that face New York,
those require your focus and your attention.
The health piece is a big piece.
I'm not sure that it really got that much focus
in the campaign.
Maybe that was intentional, maybe not, I don't know.
But that's the story that I think my audience wants to hear.
And I think it's so powerful.
It's so true.
And nothing will impact a family more than health,
things we call a chronic disease and the sick care
that we basically believe we have normalized sick care.
We don't have healthcare, we have sick care.
And I was the victim of that at 54, 55,
I received the diagnosis that I was experiencing
late stages of diabetes.
Cause vision loss.
I woke up 'cause I couldn't see the alarm clock
'cause my left eye was just shocked.
And the doctor said, "Listen,
you're gonna lose your sight in a year Eric."
And had permanent nerve damage in my hands and feet.
They were tingling all the time.
I thought it was just falling asleep.
I was overweight, did not realize that
because I looked fine to me.
But throughout the year, as you say I'm in my mid 50s.
Filling out.
Yeah right.
(laughs)
Yes and--
About 35, 40 pounds heavier?
Yeah about 35 pounds heavier.
And I had this terrible feeling in my stomach.
That's what sent me to doctor in the first place
'cause you know, men, you have to drag us to the doctor,
you suck it out.
It's got to be really bad.
Right, right.
And I thought it was colon cancer
because it was a not that wouldn't move,
it wasn't gas moving around.
And when the doctor checked me, when I came out of sedation,
he checked my colon and my stomach,
he said hey you have an ulcer.
He both, he said, but your real problems is your diabetes,
he says you in late stages.
And I went to five of the best doctors in the city
and they all told me the same thing, that it was hereditary,
that there's not much you can do.
You're going to be on insulin, the rest of your life.
You going to be on medicine the rest of your life.
And that's just, I was like, no.
(laughs)
Because my mom was diabetic for 15 years at the time,
seven years on insulin.
And I just refuse to accept that.
My sister was experiencing,
she lost a kidney through diabetes,
another sister lost a breast to breast cancer.
Another brother was going through cancer as well.
Another brother was dealing with prostate cancer.
So it was, the family was dealing with,
we were at the stage of chronic diseases
that's going to get those notifications one at a time.
But given that,
you have it throughout your family history
and you on some level conscious or otherwise
you're experiencing these symptoms,
you know something is wrong.
And you know, diabetes is probably in the cards for you.
It probably didn't come as that big of a surprise.
That that was something that you were contending with.
Where does that impulse to say, I'm not having this
and I'm going in another direction, come from?
Good that's a good question.
That's sort of at odds
with the guy who refuses to go to the doctor.
Right, right, right, right.
There was, I think that many of us, particularly men,
women are not as bad as men, but particularly men.
We sort of take this position,
of well I'll wait until next week
and we know next week never comes,
and by the time we get inside that doctor's office is like,
listen, you're in bad shape.
You going right into surgery.
(laughs)
And it was really the ulcers saved my life.
And 'cause remember diabetes is the number one cause
of non trauma limb amputation.
I was having a neuropathic nerve damage.
And it was gonna lead to that.
These number one cause of blindness.
It was, the causes of all of these other, kidney failures.
And so going to doctors
was just to deal with that pain in my stomach.
And later it gave me the pathway out.
And so they gave me these pamphlets,
all the doctors gave me pamphlets
about living with diabetes.
And I went to the computer and I typed one different word
reversing diabetes.
I couldn't even tell you where it came from.
It came from somewhere in the universe.
The idea of just writing that word reversing down.
Took me in a different search.
Living with diabetes would have been one search engine
and one direction reversing
took me in a different search path.
Right, yeah Neil Barnard pops up first probably.
Yes, been Dr. Esselstyn
and doctor was my good Gregor.
Gregor.
That's my crew.
(chuckles)
Love those guys, and I was able I started reading
and I was like, is this some national enquirer
if someone discovers someone from Mars or something so far.
Yeah.
That was a foreign term reversing chronic diseases.
I've never heard that before.
And I just dug in.
And finally I call Dr. Esselstyn in the Cleveland Clinic.
He said, fly down to see him.
And I spoke with him.
And he started telling me about what I should do.
And I remember that day sitting there,
and I was like, what's wrong with this quack?
(laughs)
I'm losing my sight.
He's telling me to give up steak and chicken,
but aint nothing to lose.
And when I went and returned to home
and went to my pantry, my refridge,
I said, "Wow, look at these labels."
We're not even eating food anymore.
The lights went on.
It did.
It's interesting, because there's something about
having your back up against the wall,
like being in that state of desperation
that will summon the willingness to actually make a change.
It's like you can educate yourself,
you could have read articles about Dr. Esselstyn
or read his book or whatever.
That's very different from actually implementing the advice,
but you are in a state of,
high agitation.
Desperation.
And motivation, right?
Which are, it's like you don't want people to suffer.
But I'm also not so quick to try to deprive people
of those moments because they can catalyze
incredible transformation.
Without a doubt, I am who I am because of that,
that experience.
And three weeks after going through
a whole food plant-based diet, my vision came back.
Three weeks.
Three weeks, when to--
How bad was your vision?
It was the doctor told me,
"Eric, you have to turn in your driver's license,
you are legally blind, you can no longer drive a car
in the State of New York."
And that first week, the food was so bad.
(laughs)
I was like, did I have to eat this?
I used to have a cereal in the morning with flaxseed
that I didn't know
that you're supposed to grind the flaxseed.
(laughs)
I was just pass right through.
Yes, but then that Sunday,
I was just in a state of just sadness.
And I said, "Eric, what's wrong with you?"
You in is always me, why not go to a why not me?
Why not learn how to cook?
Why not learn about spices?
Why not learn about different cuisines?
And I just dug into that next Monday,
I woke up with a new energy
and say every day I'm going to learn a different way
of cooking and styles and my taste buds.
And I was able to turn it around
and by the end of the second week,
my food was tasting better.
Three weeks later, I had a nice repertoire
about 10 different meals.
And three months later, my diabetes was in remission,
my nerve damage went away, the tingling was gone,
my vision was great.
Everything changed, my body just started shedding off
all of those extra pounds
and it was just an unbelievable transformation.
It's wild man.
So your A1C was like 17 and a half percent,
which for people that don't know it's almost like triple
where it's meant to be, it's down to like six now?
Yes, is at 5.8 now.
And no medication.
No medication, no medication.
People have such a hard time buying into this
or believing this but you being a living example
and being in this position of influence and power,
I just think is really is so palpable.
(upbeat music)
Coming back for more but first,
we're brought to you by the fine folks at Navitas Organics
keeping the kitchen stocked at the RRP studio
with all sorts of delicious superfood snacks and delicacies.
We got goji berries, we got mulberries,
we got golden berries, we have blueberry, hemp power snacks,
it is all happening here.
Clearly, we're all big fans of Navitas Organics
here at the studio, not only because, they make a huge
variety of delicious and obsessively source superfoods
that we use in our smoothies and other plant based meals,
but also because of their ongoing commitment to creating
a healthier world through regenerative organic farming
and plant focused lifestyles.
For more than 15 years, Navitas Organics has sourced
the highest quality organic superfoods from around the world
to keep you energized and nourished on every level.
And I love that they work with smallholder farmers
who use sustainable organic farming methods
and they operate with a focus on leaving as light
of a footprint on the earth as possible, I love it.
So here's what you're gonna do,
you're gonna visit navitasorganics.com/richroll
for a limited time offer of 30% off
your entire order of organic superfoods.
That's navitasorganics.com/richroll
for a limited time offer of 30% off
your entire order of organic superfoods.
And finally, we're brought to you today by WHOOP.
We're all trying to figure out ways to be healthier,
whether it'd be better about getting to the gym more often,
or being smarter about our nutrition, but often, not with me
or probably not with you guys,
'cause I talk about it all the time.
But for a lot of people sleep is overlooked
as a crucial part of what makes
us all perform our best every day.
In fact, tomorrow's best work is done by night
and WHOOP, a fitness tracker and app provides you
with next level insights that you need to be smarter
about sleep so that you can perform
at your best consistently.
WHOOP provides personalized insights through their app
that actually lets you know how much sleep you need,
how recovered your body is to take on the day,
and how strenuous your day was from everything you do
in and outside of training.
WHOOP is monumental when it comes to tracking my sleep.
It monitors all the sleep cycles, the stages,
the disturbances and efficiency.
And based on how strenuous your day is,
WHOOP then provides suggested sleep time
so your body is able to get the rest it needs to recover.
This part has been key to me cutting down my recovery times
over the last year
and in turn helps me push harder in my workouts.
If you're looking to be smarter about how you sleep,
recover and train so you can be at your best
you gotta check out WHOOP.
Right now for all you guys my listeners,
WHOOP is offering 15% off,
when you use the code Rich Roll at checkout.
Go to whoop.com, that's whoop.com
and use the code Rich Roll at checkout,
to save 15% off your order.
Unlock your best self today.
Okay, back to the show.
(upbeat music)
What was your diet like prior?
Like just food, what do you eaten before?
Well, I was a former police officer
so we should just still admit that we like donuts,
because yes we do.
(laughs)
How dare you?
And--
You'll get some hate for that.
And it was really just process food.
I knew where every dollar menu was located for McDonald's.
It had to be fried, sugar, process, sweet
just a real process food diet over fat, over oiled,
over sugar, white flour.
When I think about it now
I say why the human body is so resilient.
Because the food we eat is just so bad.
It's like imagine having a Maserati,
and you keep putting Windex in your gas tank.
(laughs)
It's just the body's just not made to eat what we're eating.
And still it figures out how to function with that
for quite a long time before it breakdown.
It's gonna breakdown.
And when we're faced with the prospect
of putting something good in our body we balk at the idea.
Right.
But I think it's important for people to understand
how those cravings change like,
a lot of people would imagine that okay,
you're facing this death sentence so fuck it,
like I'm just gonna I have to resign myself
to this way of eating and I'll just live my life
and martyrdom and in misery, because I have to.
But in truth as you've experienced,
your tastebuds, your cravings do change
and you begin to get excited and look forward
to these healthy foods that actually nourish you.
And I think that's a pill that people have a hard time
swallowing like they think it's an exaggeration.
No, yeah maybe that happened to you
I'm not sure I believe that
but that would never happen to me
because I can't live without, X, Y or Z fill in the blank.
Well said, and you know food is heroin,
let's be clear.
That first week I was going through withdrawal.
You know waking up.
That's rough.
Yeah Oh it was.
You may as well, you take someone hooked on heroin,
put them in one room and someone hooked on a stake
and all that other bad food and take it away,
I challenge you to tell me who's the heroin addict.
I know, when I did it I had the sweats
and I had no energy.
It took like two weeks to get over that hump.
Yes.
Then the lights go on.
The sky is clear and its a new day.
Well said, and mom she transitioned a few in April.
I'm sorry to hear that.
And she struggled with from the south
and she really leaned into the plant-based lifestyle
in two months after going, hopefully plant-based
she was able to cycle off her insulin
in two months she was 80, at 81, 82 at the time.
And, can you imagine how many loved ones we lost?
How many loved ones lost their sight?
Amputations, kidney failure, dialysis.
So when people tell me well, it's hard.
No, let me tell you was hard going to dialysis
three days a week, three hours a day, that's hard.
Yeah, well that's what Esselstyn always says,
when people say, well, this is so extreme,
this diet it's a radical.
And he's like, what's radical,
is having your chest cracked open.
(laughs)
That's radical, like this is no big deal.
Right and it's about that's why I encourage people
to, my book healthier lives.
I encourage people to really do this holistic approach,
get meditation into your life, breathing into your life,
learn how to move just beyond the bad non nutritional food
you put in your mouth,
but the non nutritional things we do spiritually,
because just as our body is a physical body,
there's an anatomy of our spirit.
And we need to ensure that we have complete nourishment
all the way around.
Yeah, I appreciate that.
I'm completely down with that, you have to approach it
from a holistic perspective, it's mind, body, spirit.
It is.
And spirit gets short shrift in our culture,
we tend to think that that doesn't really matter.
But if you don't think that the vibration
that you're taking into your being identify the information,
you choose to expose yourself to the people
you associate with that has a similar impact,
that's not that different
than the food that you're taking in.
So true.
And that's the goal then, people around you,
if they love you, they're going to be supportive,
they don't have to go on that journey with you
but they should be supportive of it.
And it is a real way to determine is this person,
the individual that should be in my life?
Because if you don't understand
that I'm trying to do this journey,
you're not supportive of that it really says a lot.
And I had a very supportive group of people around me,
and I've never tried to push my lifestyle off on people.
I give you information.
That's what the book was all about.
It was about saying, here's the information,
particularly the African American,
and the communities of color,
have much of our food is connected to our colonials pass,
this was forced on our ancestors.
And we have continued with slavery
introduced into our lives.
And I wanted to show people the real connection,
that the food you're eating is connected to slavery,
you may have left the plantation, but you're still in slave,
that great documentary coming out
of there trying to kill us,
I believe the name of it is so important.
I need my rap industry, my young artists,
my Black Lives Matter movement,
because of black lives really matters.
It's more than just George Floyd being murdered.
It's the murder that's taking place every day in our cities,
that we feed people bad food.
Yeah 100%, I'm involved in that movie
behind the scenes.
I've seen it many times,
then working with those guys on the edit a little bit.
And I can't wait for that movie to come out
because it really makes that point so beautifully.
And in a manner that I think will be impactful
to the communities that it is addressing
it's speaking that language.
It's so true, so true.
And I think it is important.
I mean, look, the cut of your jib like,
two decades as a cop, politician, African American,
soon to be mayor like, this is not the stereotypical,
quote, unquote, vegan guy.
But it makes you very interesting,
intriguing and unlikely ambassador of this type of message,
or maybe I should just say plant-based.
But I also think that that gives you a certain resonance,
because of your life experience to speak to the communities
that are so disproportionately impacted, by our food system,
our industrialized food system,
and the disproportionate impact that it has on their health,
the food deserts, the food insecurity,
the lack of consistent access to healthy food,
and how that trickles down
into the skyrocketing diabetes rates
and obesity rates and heart disease rates that we're seeing
in underprivileged communities of color all across America.
So true, so true.
And you said something that was extremely important that
about the movie,
and how it's going to speak to the language of people
who probably would not have even engaged in this at all,
because you could have the best message
but if it's not speaking the right language,
no one is going to understand it.
And this has been such a 20,000 feet message
that people on the ground,
they don't even have a clue what we're talking about.
But when we go into our senior centers, in our churches,
and other areas,
and engage in a real conversation of,
here's this guy, Eric Adams that we all knew
from his fight for police reform,
and he always had an authentic message
now he's talking about this health piece,
let's take a moment and listen to what he's saying.
And I can't tell you the number of emails, calls,
people stopped me on the street.
Oh my A1C dropped five, six points.
You now what in A1C is?
(laughs)
But they've you know, people have finally,
they believe that, wait a minute, this is not my faith.
I don't have to live like this, that's empowering.
So imagine becoming the mayor.
And now I can impact the food we're serving
the underserved communities.
This is an amazing opportunity to do it,
we get it right here in New York,
we can change this entire thinking.
What happens in New York,
sets the stage and the town for all across America,
in the world.
So it is, on a tactile level, very powerful,
but on a symbolic level, perhaps even more powerful.
Because the decisions that you're gonna make
and the policies that you're gonna push forward,
people are gonna be noticing and paying attention to that.
So in terms of that,
I mean, I know as Brooklyn Borough President,
you've made great progress
in terms of healthy nutrition in schools,
trying to reform nutrition in hospitals,
and you have this educational program at Bellevue.
So it's educating the future, the generation of doctors,
getting kids hooked on healthy food
as opposed to unhealthy food,
you've incorporated all of these principles in your office.
(chuckles)
It's a crazy situation with what you do personally,
and with all the exercise equipment, and the food prep,
and all that kind of stuff which we can talk about.
But when you cross the bridge and you're in Manhattan
and you're sitting in that chair, what's the plan?
Like how are you gonna be able to scale these ideas
to impact New York City more broadly?
And think big, really thinking big
and not being afraid to fail.
And that is we've lost our adventurous outlook.
We're explorers by existence.
If we weren't, we would be still standing on one rock,
and not exploring this entire globe.
And we need to think differently,
and surround ourselves with people
who are willing to think differently.
And that's the real problem.
We are stagnant as a nation,
we're going through the motions, which is continually,
again enough time to make the donut, no one is saying,
let's think out beyond that.
So we're going to lean into hydroponic, vertical farmers,
even as this discussion continues around,
does this soil play a more important role than not?
Let's get there.
Let's be clear on one thing, we know,
the food that we are feeding people now is unhealthy.
And not everyone is going to eat organic from the soil.
We know that fertilizer is doing a number on us.
So we're going to really push the envelope
on how do we teach children how to grow healthy food?
How do we teach children
to have a nutritional based education?
To learn the origin of food?
To learn spices in home economic classes?
I was blown away to find out the power of spices,
some spices are more healthy than the food we eat.
I like how excited you get about those spices.
(laughs)
And so the goal is,
we're going to start from the place.
We should not beat the crisis.
What you put on your grill in the backyard
is beyond my control.
But you are not going to come into a governmental agency
as a prisoner, and I'm going to feed you unhealthy food
if you're incarcerated.
As a child in ACS, I'm not feeding you unhealthy food.
If you are my health and hospital system,
you're not getting enough healthy food.
And I'm not feeding those 900 to 60,000 meals a day
in a Department of Education to be unhealthy food.
We're gonna look at wherever we're feeding,
to make sure at a minimum,
you're getting healthy, good tasting food.
So we don't feed the healthcare crisis,
because that's what we're doing now.
Right, I love the idealism of it
but I'm not as sanguine about the idea of moving
these powerful lobbying efforts and bureaucracies and unions
and everything that gets packed into
kind of calcifying these systems.
Like I know many people over the years
have tried to venture into the school lunch situation
and revamp it and make it more healthy
and a lot of people sort of retreat,
hadn't had because it's so much more difficult
than you would suspect it to be
so, is there a particular strategy that you have
for being successful where others haven't been?
That's a great question.
First you have to start off with,
is beautiful to be idealistic
but also, you must become realistic,
that realism should not take you off your path.
But you can't just live through life
through the lens of idealism.
And you scale up, that's a powerful term scaling up.
It may start with just one borrow,
let's get it right, assign out two kinks,
lets figure out, then let's scale it up to another Borough.
It may start with Oh, as we were talking,
I was talking to my team earlier,
let's just start with vertical farming growing our tomatoes,
we're no longer purchasing our tomatoes.
Let's take the trucks off the road, coming from Mexico,
let's just create a great experience in Brooklyn,
of how do we grow all the tomatoes
that the Department of Education is going to use,
is going to come from our vertical farming
where we're going to employ people,
we're going to take trucks off the road,
we're going to send the children there
and let them be part of the civic engagement
of bringing those fresh tomatoes
to places where we have food apart that.
Now they engage, Hey, you know what else we can do
now that you learn how to grow tomatoes?
Let's try some lettuce.
(chuckles)
Let's try some spinach.
We can scale up, if you tried to come in automatically
and change school food overnight,
you're setting yourself up for failure and frustration.
No, let's empower on the ground.
Let's say to Miss Jones,
"You know that asthma that your son is experiencing
that obesity that he's experiencing?
Let me show you what this food is doing to him every day."
Now that organic movement is going to change this system,
and understanding how to build organic movements
is going to allow me to be successful here.
He has a potential, the possibilities are endless
with all the rooftops that the city has to offer
and all the vacant underutilized,
lots that are sitting idle right now.
If you can get a team of Ron Finley's and Stephen Ritz's
and create excitement within the local communities
and establish education programs
that get kids plugged into this early, that's the future.
Yes it is.
And remember the economics, urban farming is here.
Urban farming is and ties into the holistic approach.
We can't talk about saving our environment
without engaging the conversation
but our overconsumption on meat and dairy.
So is a level of hypocrisy
when we point into cars and buildings.
And I tell all of my environmentalist,
Hey, don't forget to chicken feed.
When we talk about what's happening to our Amazon.
Let's be honest about this.
And that's the kind of the conversation
that I'm going to force.
I'm not going to allow us
to just take those comfortable conversation, is easy to say,
"Okay, let's do something about to build this."
No, let's do something about that steak
that you about to eat right now.
And if you're true to this,
then you're going to make the sacrifices
you're asking building owners to make.
And if you're not, they'll sit down at the table
and engage in this conversation.
Yeah,
there's gonna be some uncomfortable conversations around.
Discomfort is growth.
(laughs)
Yeah, 100% and--
It is.
It's always frustrating to hear,
quote, unquote environmentalist, speak to the issues
that relate to the Amazon et cetera
and have this blind spot
when it comes to the meat and dairy industry.
Don't you wanna talk about?
(laughs)
Yeah.
But due to conference
that's sponsored by the meat and dairy industry.
Sure, there's a lot of that.
In essence, and young people have now,
they're moving to this place of truth.
They're not going to allow hypocrisy to remain anymore.
They're now drilling into, okay, who just wants it?
What is your sponsor doing?
Right, they're very attuned to transparency.
Oh, without a doubt.
And I think any business owner
who doesn't get that is doomed from the start.
Without a doubt.
You're not
transparent about how you're making
whatever it is you're making and the distribution
that goes into the product that you're selling.
And you don't have baked into the mission statement
of your business, some form of meaningful giving back,
then, it's not gonna work.
No it's not, no it's not, no it's not.
But then we've challenged them also.
That's why the movie "They're Trying To Kill Us"
is so important, 'cause you can live in a state of denial.
But once you expose, you have to make a decision.
Yeah.
Are you going to be true to who you say you are?
Yeah, it's tough man.
Short of you having this health crisis,
could you have gotten over that hump?
Had you been who you were 10 years ago,
and you sat down and watched "They're Trying To Kill Us"
without your segment in there obviously,
would that have impacted you?
Or how would that have impacted you?
I don't believe it would have,
I believe I would have stated that,
okay that's going to happen to the next guy.
Or I would have stated,
okay, when I started receiving symptoms,
then you know what I'll think about it.
But in this space, too many young people
are watching their parents inject themselves with insulin.
And it's all about motivators.
What's your motivator?
And I love when I talk to men that experience an ED
and I give them the connection of the ajudice,
your erectile dysfunction, is based on what you're eating?
Yeah.
(laughs)
You want to motivate a man?
So it's about let me find your motivator.
Your son or daughter is going through asthma, diabetes,
Type 2 diabetes, let me show you why that baby
is going through that.
When you find a person motivator,
it will motivate them to change 'cause you are right.
You have to be motivated.
Well not only that,
you have to change the medical paradigm,
because so many people who do experience
these symptoms go to their doctor, and the doctor says,
well, here they tell them exactly what your doctor told you.
And somehow we've decided as a culture
that whatever your doctor says, cannot be challenged.
My doctor told me to do this.
That is what I'm gonna do and I can't hear otherwise.
Well said.
And so that's why we're really happy
with our Bellevue project with Dr. McMakin.
It's an amazing project.
I know she's the best.
She is, and but never received the support.
We had to really drag health in hospital ahead.
But now we have a real team with Dr. Katz, who's over H&H.
He's excited about the possibilities,
he's an amazing person there.
Although David did a presentation for us one time
at downstate to a group of doctors.
And so here we have
one of the largest hospital systems in America,
we're going to use as a laboratory for the entire country.
And when we show the evidence in a data,
can't deny it anymore.
And we're saying let's give people the options.
If you want to go the insulin route,
you have the right to do so.
But at least you should walk into your doctor's office
and learn about plant based lifestyle medicine.
Right now you don't have that option.
No, so when you're mayor,
and the New York Post headline is you could just see it,
you could write it in your mind,
Eric Adams is gonna take away your cheeseburger,
or something like that.
Like, it's a delicate line that you walk,
because you wanna be this ambassador,
this living emblem of healthy, vital living,
and yet at the same time, not be in the business
of telling people how they should be living their lives.
So true, so true.
And we clear on that.
The goal is number one, the Marines to control the beach,
the first arm of our army must be information,
we must have a major information and campaign.
They trying to kill us, all of these documentaries,
while done about food,
and what food is doing to our environment.
Remember, we control our curriculum
for the Department of Education,
we're going to make sure that those first few of months,
our young people are going to be engaged
over and over again,
about what food is doing to our country.
This is going to be a youth led movement,
because all the great movements we've had,
they were actually implemented by young people,
they blow the winds of change.
Sure.
And so by having these young people engaged
and informed, you're going to see a different energy
in the city of demanding
we don't want this in our cafeteria,
we don't want this food and we want options.
'Cause the goal is to get people to the place of saying
we want options.
We're not even there yet.
And we were successful in the vegetarian diets
we're successful with meatless Mondays.
And we have this successful,
people thought it was impossible.
Right, what was the other the initiative,
the baloney.
Right baloney.
Baloney.
Give me the processed meat.
When you start to think about it,
that we serving food that we know is a type one carcinogen.
And so when I go back and reflect on my mom,
when we were going through tough economic times,
we will go into the government to receive the surplus food,
processed cheese, can meat, powdered eggs, powdered milk.
Imagine people at their most dire and difficult time,
we are going to the government and the government is saying,
Hey, we're gonna get you food to feed your chronic disease,
instead of saying we're going to give you food
to make you healthy.
Yeah.
And I say over 45 years ago,
look what happened during COVID.
Yeah.
We fed almost 200 million New Yorkers
and the food we fed them, fed their pre existing conditions.
Instead of building they're strengthening
their immune system so they can be prepared
to fight against COVID we would give them Chicken McNuggets
and other food that was actually
harming their immune system.
Yeah, I mean every spoke in the wheel is broken,
back to this idea of this holistic organism,
whether it's the human body or the City of New York,
or the globe at large,
everything has to be functioning in balance and properly.
And right now we have a conglomerised,
industrialized food system.
That's basically synergized, with Big Pharma
to such an extent that we feed the people the food
that makes them sick, that then leads them to be dependent
on pharmaceuticals for the rest of their lives,
as you were told,
and inevitably, leads to the healthcare crisis,
not just the healthcare crisis,
but the sort of the institution of health care being broken
in and of itself that's driving, not only economic divide,
but economic disaster, as it bankrupts our country,
the costs are out of control.
And we're so quick to prescribe these medications
and so resistant to cheaper solutions earlier in that cycle
that would prevent the inevitable demise to come,
that becomes so much more costly in the end.
And is not sustainable,
we have to reach the point that we comprehend
that this system is not sustainable,
it's going to bankrupt our country,
you have millions of people who are diabetic,
a substantial number of pre diabetic waiting on deck.
The cost of just sustaining the system
is just not in the human course,
the losing loved ones are chronic disease,
you have a chronic disease, it hijacks your life,
you're no longer who you are,
you sit at a terminal in your office staring at the screen,
because you wrote about the results of that test,
the productivity is shot.
And that's what we were trying to save our country.
And it's based on this ecosystem that you're talking about,
this is not cost effective at all.
Now and the change that you wanna provoke
can't be shouldered by the individual,
you have to create environments that are conducive
to the healthier choice.
'Cause otherwise, not everybody is gonna have
their come to Jesus moment like you.
Right.
Like, so how do we catch people before that?
Well, we create environments that are conducive
to that healthy choice in the schools,
in the hospitals, in the corporations.
And I think resolving those problems,
has to deal with confronting the misalignment of incentives
that currently are at play right now.
We're incentivizing people to make the unhealthy choice,
because it's the accessible choice,
it's the cheapest choice.
And when people don't have a lot of options,
you can't fault them for making that choice,
you have to really, kind of create a new foundation
in order to compel the kind of change you wanna see
at the highest level macro.
In they need wins.
And but think about it for a moment, go back 40 years,
walk into a conference,
and all you will see, you may see a pitcher of water,
and the rest will be sugary drinks.
Go back now, you see just the opposite,
may see a picture of sugary drinks
but you'll see a whole host of different flavored water,
bottle water, we have incentivize new productivity
of tasty waters, or even the basic water
because now the motivator was there.
And I think the industry is going to change
when we start incentivizing and given different motivations
and consumer demands.
Yeah.
That's going to motivate.
And that's driven by young people.
Yes.
Fundamentally.
And, that's why every fast food restaurant now
has a beyond burger or an impossible burger.
It's not because they're altruistic,
because this is what people want and the market has spoken.
So leveraging the capitalistic machine
and trying to drive in a better direction, of course.
And it's quite possible.
Part of the solution.
And so we move,
we put the right incentives in place.
If we never forget going to a food pantry
and handing someone a beat
and it was like what do I do with this?
But if we were in those food pantries,
we will incentivize food cooking classes
of teaching people how to eat healthy,
how to prepare the food, how to make sure it's tasty,
because food must look good,
it must be good, but definitely got to taste good.
Yeah.
Well, we only have a couple minutes left.
So I think that's a great segue into, how you do this?
Because you're preparing it.
Look, nobody's busier than you are.
Like, let's be honest about it.
And somehow, you figured out how to carve out time
to essentially have control over your food
by preparing your own meals
and doing meal prep on the weekends.
But for somebody who's listening to this, you saying,
listen, I'm working two jobs,
you're telling me I gotta learn how to cook.
I got to do all this stuff, like I'm already strapped.
How am I gonna do that?
And they right, and there's several barriers.
The barrier of affordability,
we have to be honest about people believe
that eating healthy is not affordable, which is wrong.
You can grab a bag of lentils
and eat healthy for the entire week
on that $3 bag of lentils if you're in a bad budget.
With that's a healthy meal, get some kale, some lentils,
you could do everything from a mental burger,
to a mental stew, to lentil pancakes
that I made the other day.
There's so much you can do with that one bag of lentils
that you're not really stagnant in the meals
that you are preparing.
That's the same with black beans,
the same with our kidney beans.
And so the most important thing that I say to people is,
don't rush yourself through this.
Start at a slow pace because a lifestyle change
and a lifestyle change, it's not a sprint, it's a marathon
and learn some good meals.
Number one the meals that you could take your time
to prepare, your fast meals
and the meals that you can have on the go
when you come in and out of your home when you're tired
and you don't want to go to those bad meals.
Like I learned how to make oatmeal overnight.
Still cut oak you put it in a nice mason jar
with some fruits and some berries
and, whatever some cinnamon you let it sit overnight
and it actually cooks overnight in the refrige
and it's a great meal that you can have throughout today.
So there's so many tips of how to just change your mindset
of how to show you get a receipt to healthy meals.
And that's what the book, my book healthier less,
I show some great recipes.
I tell people to always go to the recipe section first,
so you can see we're not talking about walking around
with kale in your pocket all the time,
we're talking about some good tasting meals
that are comfort food and enjoyable in the process.
So walk me through your typical day
and food and exercise.
First I wanna take a quick peek
into my previous day, waking up with two two eggs in a row
with bacon and some butter on both sides
and some process jelly on it.
That is how I started my day.
That's how I broke my fast and I will gulp down
a nice 16 ounce glass of high sugar.
Let me feed your diabetes orange juice.
And so that's how I started my day every day.
Let me hit that.
I didn't even have to order it when I walked into the store
they already had it prepared for me.
But now I start with amazing smoothie.
A smoothie made out of kale,
cups of blackberries or blueberries,
and a couple of superfoods, maca powder
and other powders that are mixed in it.
I see how we always get it wrong.
But I mix it in and it is unbelievable how it holds me
throughout until mid day.
And how good I feel, my energy's up on my bed lethargic
that comes with having to process all that heavy food.
And then in the middle of the day,
probably 1:30, 2 o'clock.
I'll do a nice lintu noodles with some nutritional yeast,
mushrooms, spinach, kale.
I need to see you cook that,
you got a kitchen in your office, right?
Or I will prepare it at home
and then warm it up later.
Or I'll put it in a food warm if I'm on the road some time
I'll leave it in the food warmer.
There's some great technology out there.
If you are on the road all the time
you can plug a food Walmart up inside your cigarette lighter
'cause you shouldn't be smoking anyway.
What are your cigarette lighter
and it keep it nice warm for you.
So look at the technology that's out there
that can actually assist you in getting the healthy meals
so you don't make those bad stops or chop off some fruits,
and just nibble on that throughout today.
I'll make myself a nice stew.
I have a grace stew that I love made out of mushrooms.
I will liquefy the mushrooms with other spices
and then mix it with a chop vegetables and other things.
Awesome sweet potato cornbread
and wrap it up eat it throughout today.
My three ingredients ice cream late at night,
when I just wanna have some comfort food, frozen bananas,
fresh made peanut butter and cocoa powder
with some berries and some other chopped fruits.
And I'm telling you, it is the bomb made of häagen-dazs.
You talk about all the time.
(laughs)
And how much time goes into the meal prep
and I wanna sort of dispel this idea that it's
completely time consuming, consuming all your time.
Just the opposite.
Sundays during the day--
You don't have a chef at home was doing it for you?
No, no this is all on me.
Sunday during the day or Saturday night,
I'll take out my veggie processor, food processor,
any food processor, and I will chop up my kale, my spinach,
my lentils, my bok choy.
and I put it in Tupperware so that it's ready.
So during the week, I'm just grabbing a handful of each,
put it into my salad mixer, already will have my fruits,
cut up for the week, already know how I'm going to do
my smoothies during the week.
So this way, I'm ready to go, on a night before
I can make my smoothie,
'cause starting how you break your fast
is really how you're going to start your day.
You can get in that smoothie every day,
a good healthy smoothie in a good salad, leafy salad.
That's a great start for you,
as you move throughout the day.
Yeah, I think just making those steps
kind of invest you,
it connects you emotionally what you're doing.
And over time that makes you more interested
in taking the next step.
Without a doubt, without a doubt.
We're almost out of time here.
But maybe a good way to close this is to leave people
with some thoughts on
how to effectively make this transformation,
you spoke about making sure
to the extent that you can control it, having support,
like having your inner circle be supportive
of positive lifestyle changes that you're trying to make,
like what else has been important
or do you think is crucial for people to understand?
Or really tap into this.
It surprises me for over 50 years, how wrong I was living.
And I encourage people that person that they always want it
is still there, it didn't go anywhere, that amazing person
that you know you are, it is there.
If you struggle with weight all your life,
if you struggled with how you respond
in the heat of the moment,
if you found yourself being short tempered,
if you find yourself always the lethargic, constipated,
tired, angry, you can actually have a complete reversal,
from your diet, to learning breathing.
We've never been taught how to breathe, it's unbelievable.
The most important thing you could do for yourself.
We've never been taught we never sat down
and taught children, this is how you're suppose to breathe.
How do you deal with stress?
How do you deal with anxiety?
And so go on this amazing journey,
of watching how you really started taking care
this most important person in your life and that's yourself.
And you will never believe, the human being you knew
you could always become
is going to slyke materialize out of nowhere.
And I just encourage people just to take the leap of faith.
Start slowly, don't try to change overnight,
just slowly start if you just say,
let me just go read up on spices.
Let me learn about nutmeg, and garlic, and cinnamon,
and tumeric.
And this time, let me just try one day a week
not having meat.
And you're gonna find out the sun comes out.
(laughs)
And then start.
Let me just learn about these different breathing exercises
that have been around for thousands of years.
And what meditation actually is.
And people are going to slowly start
adding things to their repertoire, more and more things
and they are going to find themselves
becoming this totally different human being
but a human being that they always were.
And then they're going to really start not just existing
they're gonna start living life every day.
I think he's stuck the landing my friend.
(laughs)
If this whole Mayor thing doesn't work out,
I see a future in a preacher or something.
(laughs)
Amazing, thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
Like I said at the outset,
there are so many other things
I'd love to talk to you about
so perhaps we can continue this at a future day.
But I'm so excited for,
what's to come for you the future of New York.
Congratulations on everything and I wish you well
and I'm at your service.
Thank you, we look forward to keeping you updated.
Yeah absolutely.
So as we move on one year, two year, three year,
four year to see the productivity.
I'm gonna hold you to it.
Yes.
(laughs)
Accountability, right?
You wanna surround yourself with people
who are supportive but also hold you accountable.
Without a doubt, that's why I have the earing.
Yeah, you do right?
The book is "Healthy at Last," everybody pick it up,
"A Plant-Based Approach to Preventing and Reversing Diabetes
and Other Chronic Illnesses" by Mr. Eric Adams
soon to be Mayor of New York City.
And I will talk to you again my friend.
Yes, thank you.
All right, peace, plants.
(upbeat music)
Thanks for listening everybody.
For links and resources
related to everything discussed today,
visit the show notes on the episode page at richroll.com.
If you'd like to support the podcast,
the easiest and most impactful thing you can do
is to subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts, on Spotify,
and on YouTube.
Sharing the show or your favorite episode with friends
on social media is of course always appreciated.
And finally, for podcast updates, special offers on books,
the meal planner and other subjects.
Subscribe to our newsletter which you can find on the footer
of any page on richroll.com.
Today's show is produced and engineer by Jason Camiolo.
The video edition of the podcast
was created by Blake Curtis,
portraits by Allie Rogers and Davey Greenberg.
Graphic elements courtesy of Jessica Miranda.
Copywriting by Georgia Whaley
and our theme music was created by Tyler Pyatt,
Trapper Piatt and Harry Mathis.
You can find me at richroll.com
or on Instagram and Twitter @richroll.
I appreciate the love.
I love the support.
I don't take your attention for granted.
Thank you for listening.
See you back here soon.
Peace, plants.
(mumbles)
(upbeat music)